hello everyone in this video we plan to
talk about how to use google cloud to
build infrastructure for your website
that is scalable highly available and
widely distributed
today's presentation has two parts the
first provides a high level overview of
what infrastructure pieces are involved
and how they fit with each other
as a brief introduction i'm karthik a
product manager within google cloud
the second part walks you through the
details of how to use gcloud to actually
build the infrastructure end-to-end and
will be covered by my colleague armand
rai while there are many options
available the key insight we want to
drive is to showcase how google cloud
can be used as a one-stop shop for
building scalable highly available
websites that can be distributed all
across the globe with relatively low
effort
here are the products that we will cover
in this video
let's start at the very beginning buying
and registering a domain
until now this process was outside
google cloud and it was not very
straightforward to buy register verify
the ownership and set up dns records so
that your customers can reach your
website
we have recently launched google domains
that is integrated into google cloud to
offer a more seamless workflow and to
manage your domain's lifecycle
cloud domains allows you to check for
availability of the domain name and
purchase it it will also register this
domain and verify the ownership
finally it supports api so you can
programmatically manage your gaming
portfolio
once domain has been registered the next
step is to create dns records so your
customers can visit your website
cloud dns offers public dns zones that
are accessible worldwide and has high
availability and scalability
we will create a public dns zone for the
new domain you've just registered in
this step
cloud dns also supports dns and enabling
it is very easy
dns is used to defend against techniques
that hackers use to direct computers to
rogue websites and servers
we will need to add dns records to this
zone before it's reachable by your
customers but we will do that in a
different step
as next steps we will create the
back-ends
this represents the actual web server
that runs your website we will split
this into two parts
use managed instance group for serving
your website this represents compute
virtual machines that process income
incoming requests and identify what
actions to take
we use managed instance groups primarily
because you can control them as a single
entity and because it is easy to scale
when the demand for your website
increases say during a holiday season
managed instance groups work by using a
template that you create the template
defines machine type wood disk image or
container image and other instance
properties
once created you can either create
individual vms or groups of vms
and control them as a single entity
you can manually set the size of the
number of vms or use auto scaling if
your website is stateless
the managed instance group automatic
updater also lets you safely deploy new
versions of software to your mig and
supports um a flexible range of rollout
scenarios such as rolling updates and
canary updates
you can control the speed and scope of
deployment as well as the level of
disruption to your service
finally you can deploy this in multiple
gcp regions increasing your fault
tolerance and availability
next we use cloud storage for static
content like images backgrounds videos
and other portions of the website that
don't change frequently
cloud storage allows you to store large
quantities of data that can be accessed
worldwide more importantly it offers
high availability with multiple
redundancy options it also makes it easy
to ingest your media content on the one
end and makes it easy to distribute over
a content delivery network like cloud
cdn or another provider
after creating backends we will create
the front end that will handle the
traffic to your website
google cloud https load balancing is a
global proxy based layer 7 load balancer
that enables you to run and scale your
services worldwide behind a single
external ip address
it does much better than dns based load
balancing because there are no ttls
involved and the load balancer can
respond much quicker to changes in
traffic patterns or health of the
backends
it also allows you to do content-based
load balancing using url maps to select
the appropriate backend service
finally you can run within google's
premium tier networking that will offer
cross-regional load balancing and
allowing you to direct traffic to the
closest healthy backend that has
capacity
now it's time to add some security by
adding cloud armor to the incoming
traffic
cloud armor sits at the google edge and
provides ddos protection along with
predefined rules that defend against
crash site scripting and sql injection
attacks
you can also create custom ip based
allow and deny lists and prevent
malicious users from consuming your
resources
here's an overall picture that shows how
everything is put together
with that i hand it over to armand who
will go over the same steps but in much
greater detail
thanks cartech
my name is arman rai and i am a network
specialist at google cloud
for this portion of the presentation i
will walk you through an example
deployment on google cloud from start to
finish
we will go from ordering a domain all
the way through verifying that all the
appropriate features are enabled
let's get started we will begin our demo
with the domain registration process
the first step is to check that the
domain you would like to purchase is
available
running the search domains command will
give you a list of tlds and the
associated prices
even though we have specified a com in
the search the result will give many
tlds that are available for purchase
once you have decided on the domain name
you would like to purchase and confirmed
it is available you need to create a
cloud dns zone with a domain name
this zone is where you will manage dns
for this domain
make sure you set the dns sec state to
on to utilize the security benefits of
dns sec
next you will actually need to order the
domain
the gcloud response from the registrar
command will prompt you to add
information about your business and list
a point of contact
the final step is to link the dns zone
that we created in step 1 to the domain
cloud domains
this will ensure that the appropriate
name server records as well as the
appropriate ds records are added for dns
sec
a great feature of the gcp platform is
that this step is automated for you so
you don't need to do it yourself
we strongly encourage customers to use
gcp for both their dns and registrar
needs due to these increasing product
synergies in this demo we will be
configuring two backends one for static
content like images logos or videos
and the other for dynamic content like
html and any apis your website relies on
let's start with the static content
first we create a storage bucket for
this bucket we have chosen to have it be
regional in our u.s east 1 location and
to use the standard storage class
second we must add some content to the
storage bucket
in a typical deployment there are many
options on how to upload content to a
storage bucket please see our
documentation for further information
about how to do so
third we will update the bucket
permissions to public so that anyone can
access the contents stored
you can additionally leverage im
permissions if you would like to
restrict access to the bucket but we
will not be covering that in this demo
now that we have set up our static
content storage bucket we will pivot to
dynamic traffic
before we can create a managed instance
group we must create a template which
will be the blueprint for all of the
compute we will utilize
there's a lot of metadata you can add in
this template in this example we have
picked a region for the compute to be
deployed
a vpc network that my networking is
utilizing as well as a specific subnet
which i want my compute instances to
utilize we have additionally specialized
specified an image for the compute and a
simple startup script to install apache
and run a basic web server
now that we've created the template for
our dynamic traffic to use we need to
instantiate the actual instance group
the first command creates the instance
group using the template we just created
the second command specifies that we are
running our web application on port 80.
in this demo we are using http for the
back end of our load balancer since all
traffic is on google's private network
if you'd like you can additionally run
https traffic on port 443 for your back
ends
before we get into creating the load
balancer i want to spend a few moments
discussing what are the different
components from a g cloud perspective
that are required starting from the left
in this diagram we need a globally
accessible static ip address this is the
ip address that will correspond to our
load balancer and is linked using a
forwarding rule
second we have the actual proxy itself
we need to create two proxies one for
http and one for https
the global http load balancer is a proxy
load balancer so this step is required
third we need to input some logic that
defines how traffic is routed between
our dynamic backends and our static back
ends
this configuration is called the url map
finally we need to identify the
different ends that we want the traffic
to be sent to
one for our static bucket and one for
our instance group
in addition we need to configure whether
we'd like to use cloud cdn for content
caching or cloud armor for security
there are two steps we need to take
before we start configuring the load
balancer
we need to reserve a static ip address
for our load balancer to use
a common mistake in this step is not to
specify the global flag
once we have reserved it we need to list
it
please save this ip address for later in
the demonstration
it's worth mentioning that as long as
this address this ip address is in your
static ip addresses
this ip will be able to be utilized by
any of your by your resources in your
gcp project
additionally we need to make sure that
the firewall in our vpc is set to allow
traffic from the slash 16 and slash 22
cider ranges listed
if you do not do this step your health
checks will be blocked and no traffic
will be able to reach your back end
now we can get started with configuring
our load balancer
in this first command we create a basic
health check which will probe our back
end on port 80. this command utilizes
the default settings
know that there are a lot of
customizations available beyond the
defaults for health checks but we will
not be covering in them in this session
health checks are a very powerful tool
which allow for only healthy back ends
to receive end user traffic
the second command creates a back-end
service which we will attach to our back
ends too
you need to attach a health check to the
back-end service
once we have created our back-end
service we need to add the back-ends to
it the first command adds our dynamic
back-end service to the back end
the second command creates a back-end
bucket for our static content
additionally we are including the enable
cdn flag in our request
by turning on the cdn we are ensuring
that static content is served globally
from google's edge caches instead of
from the direct from the bucket every
time
by doing so we are greatly increasing
the speed of the website
cloud cdn by default will cache static
file types
google determines file type by looking
at the mime type of the response from
origin
we then map the mime type to a list of
static content mappings that we maintain
if you do not want to utilize this
method for cache control no problem you
can set your own cache control headers
at origin
or you can configure a force cache all
setting
be careful when setting the force cache
all setting because you may
inadvertently end up caching content
that is intended to be dynamic i.e
non-cacheable
the third command here adds a custom
response header to requests for this
back end
the custom response header indicates
whether or not the request was served
from the cdn cache
there are a lot of other custom headers
that can be added in addition to the
cache status
you can additionally add your own
headers and set them to be whatever
you'd like
once the back-ends are created we need
to create a url map
the url map is a construct that is used
to determine traffic routing between our
backends
the first command creates the url map
object
in this command we are specifying that
the default location for traffic to be
sent to
is our dynamic backend
the second command adds the logic that
any traffic destined to the path or
directory slash images
star should instead be sent to the
backend bucket you can add many
different paths here but for our demo
we're just going to use one
additionally it's worth mentioning that
there are many more advanced routing
capabilities available to you beyond
path matching in the global https load
balancer
the full list of attributes that you can
route on in the url map is listed in our
documentation as well as guidance on how
to deploy this
in this section we will create the
proxies and order an ssl certificate to
be served at our edge
the ssl certificate will be issued by
google's certificate authority or let's
encrypt
there are a lot of customizations
available within ssl at gcp you can
specify for example which tls versions
you would like to support
or what cipher suites you would like
clients to support as well
in this example we're going to stick
with the defaults
the first command creates the http proxy
this is linked to the url map which we
created in the previous step
the second command orders an ssl
certificate
there are no validation records we need
to add since we are using cloud dns
and later we will point traffic to the
static ip assigned to this load balancer
the ssl certificate will take a few
minutes to provision
but it will be done automatically
we need to make sure however that we
specify all of the host names that we
want listed here in the certificate
even while the ssl certificate is
provisioning we can use this ssl
certificate
to attach to our https proxy which is
what we are doing in step 3.
the last step of the load balancer is to
attach the static ip to the http and
https proxies step 1 attaches the ip to
the http proxy and step 2 attaches the
ip to the https proxy
by doing this the ip address which is
announced globally will be accessible
from the internet on both ports 80 and
443
we aren't covering it in this demo but
you can do an http to https redirect in
the load balancer you can also set hsts
response headers if you would like all
future requests by the same client to
use https no matter what
one of the last steps in our demo is to
create a google cloud armor policy
cloud armor is google's ddos and web
application firewall solution
before we configure it i want to quickly
explain how cloud armor works and how it
is provisioned
cloud armor similar to cloud cdn is
available as part of the global https
load balancer
cloud armor consists of security
policies
a security policy is a collection of
rules
rules can be custom firewall rules or
particular protections included in the
owasp top 10.
a cloud armor rule has a priority
associated with it
similar to the vpc firewall the lower
the priority number the higher up in the
match hierarchy a given rule is
a security policy is attached to a
back-end service
a back-end service can only have one
security policy associated with it
a security policy can be reused however
across multiple back-end services
to configure cloud armor we must first
create a security policy
the security policy will contain the
rules that are applied to our dynamic
content backend
once the security policy has been
created we can then create an example
rule
the example rule i created will block
any traffic that contains the http
request header called evil header
i have also specified that i would like
to respond to this traffic with a 403
response code
this custom rule utilizes the common
expression language or cell
this is an open source language designed
for simplicity speed safety and
portability
i want to take this moment to
additionally highlight that there is an
implicit rule in cloud armor security
policies which dictates whether traffic
is allowed or blocked by default for
that security policy
if we do not specify this flag in the
first command it will default to an
allow setting
this translates to any traffic that does
not match any of the rules we configure
will be let through
now that we have a security policy and
an example rule
the remaining step is to apply it to a
back end the second step here is an
optional one but a recommended step
it enables cloud armor's adaptive
protection feature
adaptive protection builds machine
learning models which detect and alert
on anomalous application level activity
it additionally generates a signature
describing the attack as well as
generates a custom google waff rule to
block the detected signature
adapt adaptive protection is in public
preview as of the time of this recording
it's worth mentioning as well that the
custom rule that
that adaptive protection generates is
not automatically deployed applied there
is an alerting mechanism and you as the
user can decide whether or not you want
to deploy this rule for your back end
now that everything is set up the only
task we have left to do is to point dns
to the ip we reserved for our load
balancer earlier in the presentation we
highlighted how to reserve and obtain
this static ip address
if you didn't get a chance to write it
down you can always go back and re-list
your static ip addresses for your
project
the dns g cloud integration utilizes a
concept called a transaction
to add any new records you must begin a
transaction
you can see this command in step one
where we start a transaction for our
zone
once the transaction has begun you need
to specify the records you would like to
add
in this example since we are only adding
two records i've explicitly listed them
individually
if you have many records you can upload
your records using a bind file
for this demonstration we will be adding
a www record and an apex record pointing
to the static ip address we configured
earlier
now that we have added the records we
can complete our transaction
once the transaction completes the
change then propagates to our edge and
traffic will be routable for the dub dub
dub and apex domains
we have completed the setup for our demo
now for a final few checks we can make
sure that everything is functioning as
it is supposed to
the first check is perhaps the most
obvious i'm able to access the image we
uploaded to our storage bucket
at the url listed www.gcpwebdemo.com
images snowboarding.jpg
this site is accessible over https i've
included a screenshot of the certificate
information from my browser
no warnings are prompted and the correct
common name is listed
the certificate is valid and has not
expired
additionally you could see that the
organization is google trust services
for this particular certificate
next we will verify that cloud cdn is
running and that static content is being
cached at google's edge as we expected
it to
i've sent a curl to an image in the
storage bucket we created the
snowboarding.jpg
in the response i can see the custom
response header we added gcp-status
with the value hit
this means that the response was served
from a gcp edge cache and not from the
bucket directly
by using cloud cdn you're able to
improve origin offload and reduce egress
costs
while simultaneously increasing the
response speed for the end user
to test that cloud armor is working we
can send a curl request including the
header name evil header
we configured the cloud armor security
policy with a rule that explicitly
blocks traffic with this header
the response from the curl is a 403
forbidden which is exactly what we
expected and consistent with what was
configured
thank you for listening to this
presentation and demo we hope you found
it useful
please add your questions to the
comments if you have any
thanks